can you hear me in the back? Awesome. Let's start. So my name is Ewan Bilan and today
we're going to talk about this new paradigm in NLP called self-attention. So actually
like couple of months ago I saw this blog post by Eugenio Culorcello and he writes, drop
your RNNs, drop the LSTM, don't use those anymore. You don't need that. You only need
attention. Attention is all you need, right? And when I read this I was like, what? Like
we did this for three or five years and we were so successful and now we're just supposed
to throw it away. So in this talk I'm going to answer this question, like can we actually
skip the whole part and just use attention? So let's take a quick step back. I'm currently
studying computational linguistics at the LMU. I'm also studying technology management
at the same time. I'm doing a lot of research mainly in relation extraction, author profiling,
author obfuscation and stuff like that. If you're interested in any of those come up
to me later. And I also work as a part-time data engineer at TrustU. So just very quickly
at TrustU we do automated summarization. We collect a lot of reviews from the internet
and then for each hotel in the world, based on the reviews they get, we output like one
sentence summary like for 600,000 hotels. Okay, so let's jump right in. First let's take a
look at how the sort of neural NLP has developed. So we all started with RNNs. In an RNN you
can get a sequence, a sentence, and then you just go from the first one to the last and
encode information and in the end it sort of outputs an encoder that is like a sentence
embedding. But there RNNs didn't really work that well. Well, they are a bit more complex
than that, but there is a problem of like the gradients not propagating properly, you're
losing a lot of information. So that's why people came up with long-short-term memory
and gated recurrent units. So basically it's an improvement or RNN which just adds up more
logic that helps the model decide whether the input is important or not and should I
propagate it to the next step. So they use sort of something called gating mechanisms
and this is the whole logic that's in there. Well, people also use CNNs for NLP. Well, when
I first started this was really weird for me. Like how can you use a CNN for NLP? Well,
the best way to think about this is in the image you have pixels and then you have sort
of height and width. You actually, and then you do like max pooling and stuff like that
or that. Well, actually you have the same thing in sentences because your height is
like the number of words in the sentence and the width is the dimensionality of the embedding
of word-to-vec embedding, for example. So that's how you can use CNNs. And LSTMs are
often used in an architecture that we call encoder-decor or sequence-to-sequence. Especially
this is used in neural machine translation where you input a sentence in German and then
it will output a sentence in English. And this looks kind of like this. So the red part
is the encoder. You can use LSTM, GRU, whatever you want. And somehow you encode the sentence
and create a vector Z that is sort of like a sentence embedding. And then you give the
sentence embedding to your decoder model, which can also be an LSTM but doesn't have
to. And then it will sort of translate it. So this is a really nice example where it's
translating an idiom from German. It's actually translated correctly in English and says it's
an awesome sauce. Right. But, so LSTMs were kind of created to deal with this vanishing
gradient problem. So the information, not propagating. And sort of LSTMs were supposed
to fix this. But this is a sentence. This is like, I don't know, 50 words long. This
is from Word and Peace by Leo Tolstoy. And like, are we supposed to use an LSTM for that?
That's not really going to work. So what's the solution here? We move on to attention
mechanisms. You can use attention to improve LSTMs as well as CNNs, either for NLP or
for image recognition. So let's first start with understanding images. This is a model
from DeepMind. And it sort of hops over the image but only attends to the most important
part. So here it's classifying like house numbers. And you see, it doesn't scan the
whole image. It only scans the part that has the number in there. Well, actually it's
very similar in NLP. When you read the text, you often skim through it. You don't really
read the whole thing all the time. And maybe only some parts of it are important, some
and all. So this is a sort of model that uses LSTMs as attention to do summarization of
restaurant reviews and beauty salon reviews. And you can see the red part is actually where
the model is paying the most attention. So it's saying like, this is a nice place, my
favorite restaurant, food is incredible, and so on. So the model is actually selecting
the stuff that's important for the summarization. And you can also use this attention in the
in-coder decoder model when you're translating from one language to another. You see that
the width of those lines actually show you how much attention the word you're going to
translate is paying to other words in the sentence. So the bigger it is, the more attention
it pays to it. It's a bit more complex than that. There are a lot of formulas. But when
you deal with attention, you can either use it for translation, but you can actually use
it for simple document classification. Like you can just create an attention or a word
to both the sentence embedding and then over that, you can build sort of document embedding
based on the sentences. And you will only attend to the sentences that actually should
contribute to your classification. So I'm not going to go over the formulas, but when you deal
with attention, most of the time they look like this. So the first part, the U is the context
factor. And there are many ways how you can do this. So there's no standard way for attention.
That is why in PyTor's TensorFlow, there is no layer called attention. You just have LSTMs
and RNNs because there are so many of them. But the next part is almost always the same. You
just do like a softmax operation to get the probability and then use those probabilities
to improve your LSTM or whatever you're using. Right. So actually, this helps a lot. On the
left side, you see in neural machine translation, we use a blue score to say how accurate the
translation is. And if the sentence has more words, has more than 40 words, then it sort of
goes down. But on the right side, where you have attention, that sort of stays stable even
if sentences are really long, like 60 words or even more. So that works quite well. Well,
actually, it also helps you to see what the model is learning, what's it attending to.
So you can look at those weights, what words are contributing to other ones. So you can look at
individual words, let's say this from French to English. This word is translated and it looks
to economic area or whatnot. And then you do another one. And sort of you can also debug your
model this way, but also sort of visualize it. Right. So we saw we can use attention to improve
LSTMs, but it's also possible to skip the whole LSTM CNN part and use attention. So this was
so first done by Google Brain. They published a paper in July 2017. So a year ago, where they
don't have any convolution, no recurrence, it's just layers of attention. And sort of very high
level overview, it just takes one word and then compares it to all the other words and tries to
get the similarity. And it's like a set operation. It doesn't care where the word is. So it just
compares everything to everything. And then based on that, it encodes this information,
presses it to the decoder. Then the decoder can also attend to separate words. Right. So the model
is actually quite complicated, but we'll try to figure it out at least on a more higher level.
So on the left side, you have the encoder and the right is the decoder. Basically, there are only
few like specific layers in there that are then just repeated or used in like different
constellation. So we start with our sentence, which is encoded in word to work or whatever.
And I told you it's a set operation. Right. So it's like the model doesn't know where the words
are positioned. So they also actually had this very interesting idea of instead of passing like
indices of words where the words are situated in the sentence, they use
wavelengths functions to generate a wave that will then show where the word is in the sentence.
I'm going to show you more example and that just keep that in mind. After that, you have this block,
the whole encoder. And in the encoder first, you have multi head attention, which is like
actually the soul of the whole architecture. This is the self attention itself. So we're going to
look into that in more detail, but let's talk on the, like, let's see what it is on the higher
level. You have also residual connections. You probably know that from like imaging algorithms
where you, where you do something with the input, you don't want to lose too much information.
So in the beginning, you make a copy of it and then add it up at that copy to your output later
that you sort of still keep that information. And then in the end, after the, the soul multi
head attention, they have a sort of four feed forward network that is trying to figure out
what the attention was outputting. So it's very simple, like using activation function,
weights and biases. And in the end, you have to somehow, sorry, to somehow to normalize the
output. So you've probably heard about batch normalization or lay normalization. So the
authors here using layer normalization for neural machine translation. For them, it works quite
well. Right. And then the decoder is sort of almost the same. It's just structured a bit
differently. An important part now you, you can also have like multiple layers. So the encoder
can be like six layers. It's the same that you would do with LSTM. So you can also have like
multiple layers of LSTM. And then the multi head attention, it's also like copied, but you're
going to look into that very soon. So I told you about the positional encodings in the form of
a wavelength. So basically the authors say, Hey, I'm going to give, I'm going to have this function
where I give the index position of reward. And then I do some like mass magic with some constants.
And in the end, I'm going to get a wavelength. So it can easily be easily visualized like this.
But this is another visualization of that. So you can see there, like this is word number
index zero, word one, two, three, and so on. And then for each position in a sentence,
it's kind of generating those things. And actually the, the authors say, Oh,
that doesn't really make that much difference. What they do here, you can just use like typical
positional embeddings. But there's one difference. When you like, during your training, you see
only sentences that are up to length 60 words. So when you're predicting and the sentences are
longer than the 60 words, and you're just using like learned positional embeddings,
then we're going to work because your model has never actually seen word at position 61 or 62,
because that wasn't present in the training model. So, but, but here, if you use this function,
you just say, Hey, here's position 62, generate me this wavelength. So this can actually help the
model to work with even longer sentences. Right. But this is very absolute. So it's just encoding
it for one position. Then there was like a follow up research by the same authors. Basically,
they say, Hey, we can have relative positional embeddings. So let's look at the context.
Let's see, maybe they have a window towards before the word I'm looking at
towards after that word. And then I'll try to also get the context. How are the embeddings
looking for that word? Yeah, so actually at the LMU in my university, we had this idea as well,
even before the paper was published. But we have a sort of different implementation. We also use
relative embeddings. But instead of having a window that sort of moves, we use something called
positional bidding. So let's say next word is very important to me. The word after that is also
important, but words like three, four, five, they're not so important. So let's bend them up in one
class sort of, and they all get the same weights. And then if they are even longer, far away,
then make the bin even bigger. So yeah, well, the attention, the multi had attention, the sort of
soul of the architecture is actually very simple. I'm going to explain everything. So it uses this
idea that you can use queries to extract some values. And the query is your word encoding. And
then you somehow create those two matrices keys that you can do similarity with and then values. So
I showed you, I told you in the beginning, I take one word and then just try to look how similar
are other words in the sentence to the word I'm looking at now. And in order to do this
efficiently and fast, you have to have these separate matrices to do that. So let's go over an
example. Say I have the sentence, right? It's from word one until word n. And my words are encoded
with word to act over terror. So in the original model, they have 512 dimensions. And then you do
the positional stuff that we talked about, you just add them up. So you sort of also add this
information where the words are situated in the sentence. And then let's say, okay, let's look at
one word, word at position x2. I want to see how similar are other words to that one. So I use
something called compatibility function. And I say at position two, look at position one, look at
position three and four and so on. And let's find out how similar they are. And you can do this
by using this trick with key matrices. And in the end, extract the similar words using the value
matrices. So if I do this for position two and one, I get some sort of similarity. Maybe this word
is a bit similar. When I compare it to itself, of course, it's the most similar because the word
in the sentence is most similar to itself. And then let's say, for example, the word three is
even more similar to that than the word one. Word four is even more. So that means, hey, I need to
pay attention to this word four when I'm looking at word two because somehow it's similar. And you
do this for the whole sentence. And now you have to somehow use it. So you can run a softmax
operation. Basically, softmax will give you a probability distribution over all of those
similarities that you have just computed. And now you can use this probability to create this top
level z vector. It's like we saw in the encoder, LSTM creates those z vectors that are sort of like
a sentence embedding. And here, you're basically doing the same thing, but you're not using
recurrence or anything else. You're just using this attention mechanism with similarity. And then
you do this trick where you multiply this similarity probability with this other matrix
of values. And then this is how you're encoding in the end looks like, right? And you do this
couple of times, basically, you multiply your heads, and you have different heads. And actually,
they are in the beginning the same, but all of them have different weights. So they learn
something else, each of them learned something else. So the head on the left, sort of here,
you can see it looks very closely to the words next to it. And the word on the head on the right,
it kind of attends to words that are further away, right? So it's sort of learning something from
there. And then there are also other examples where somehow figures out, like, a reference
what are words referring to, like if I have the animal cross the street because it was too tired,
or didn't cross the street. And then the it, it was too tired. The head can actually figure out
what it is referring to. Is it referring to animal or to the street? So yeah. And then
when you try to reimplement this model yourself, you'll just go and fail because there are so
many details. It's just ridiculous. A lot of constants, lots of stuff. One example is you
can't really train it the usual way. You have to do learning rate warm up, which means you start
with a learning rate zero. And then you increase it gradually over like 4,000 epochs. And after
epoch 4,000, you, you sort of decay it. And for some reason, this works better when you're doing
like neural machine translation. And then this model is training for like 300,000 epochs. But
that's probably because it's Google, right? They have tons of data. So they need more time.
Right. So don't, don't do this from scratch. There is an official library from Google created in
TensorFlow. There are also other ones in MX NAT, in PyTorch. And you can also find like really
nice blocks to try to go or the code and explain how it is sort of implemented.
Right. So we saw self-sufficiency can be used for neural machine translation, but there are
actually other applications. And again, Google Brain, they used it for something else. They tried to
quickly summarize text like based on Wikipedia articles. And then they can also generate new
Wikipedia articles like fake ones. And they have an example where the model generates a
Wikipedia article about the Japanese metal band. It was like Japanese names and cities and whatever,
and it looks so real, but it's actually totally fake. The model has learned to sort of create those
texts itself. Then we, at our university, a team of researchers used it for like relation
argument extraction. So we're going to come back to that in a bit. Then there's some research by
Berkeley University. They used self-sufficiency in color to improve constituency parsing, and they
are actually beating the state of the art, which I think was previously like LSTM based. And then
right now there's a lot of research going on into self-sufficiency by OpenAI. They're saying, hey,
we trained this like task agnostic language model that can do lots of stuff like question
answering, a textual entainment reasoning, and it's all based on sort of self-attention.
This is, there is a preprint. It's not published. They're still working on it, but it's really cool.
And you can see the dates. It's like everything is like super new. This all happened in 2018. So
this area of research is like really new, but also very exciting. So just quick note, Google is not
the only one doing this. There is also another self-attention model, which is called DSAN,
like Directional Substantion. We're not going to talk about that because that would need another
presentation, but just so you know, there are other options to do this. Okay, so now I want to
introduce our research from the LMU. We actually used a self-attention in color to do a relation
classification, and this is done together with Benjamin Roth. He's a professor of computational
linguistics at LMU, and we basically worked on this for the last half a year or something.
So what is a relation extraction? Let's first have a couple of examples. So in relation to
extraction, you try to extract some information from sentences. You have two entities in the
sentence, and then you try to find, hey, what is the relation between those entities? For example,
relation person employee of, you will figure out, hey, does this person X work for a company Y
over terror? And I have an example for that. For example, sentence go, AIG intends to sell shares
in American life insurance, blah, blah, blah, said Fumio Shisado, a Tokyo-based spokesman for AIG.
So you have two entities. One is Fumio Shisado, the other one is AIG, and then you tell, hey,
look into this, and what is the relation here? What is there is a relation in this sentence
between Fumio Shisado and AIG? And then the model looks at the sentence, and based on the
what the sentence has, like all the other context words, it decides what relation it is.
So, yeah, and why you need a relation extraction, basically, you use it in many ways. First, you
can create knowledge databases, ontologies, you can use it in question answering, summarization.
This technique is even used in biology to find protein interactions, and there are many use
cases for this. So, before we had, like, neural NLP, we had this feature-based approach. It did
some parsing and stuff, and it had rules, and one of the rules is, hey, look, if there exists some
dependency tree that is no longer than two words and whatnot, so this was like state-of-the-art
until 2015, and then came along some neural models, we used CNNs, we used LSTMs, and they
improved a lot the state-of-the-art, and sort of the final state-of-the-art, up until now,
was from Stanford, Stanford NLP, they had this idea to use an LSTM with attention,
but they improve attention, they call it position-aware attention, so actually,
I told you, in relation extraction, you have two entities, and what they do is they encode
separate positional embeddings for those entities, so they say, oh, my first entity is at position
five, so let's create like an embedding for that, and my another entity is somewhere in the end of
the sentence, so I have a different positional embedding for that, right, and then they use LSTM,
and I told you, like, you're going to see this formula a lot, because that's basically how you do
attention, and as I've told you, they sort of have their own idea of how to create this context
vector, and the rest is the same, and also they didn't just create the model, they also
created a really nice dataset, it's quite huge, it's 120,000 examples, and it actually has 42
relation classes, which is a lot, and it's relation classes like for persons and for organizations,
and one thing is, this dataset is very complex, because 80% of it is like examples where there
is no relation, let's say you have a sentence, Mike is working as a, I don't know, a teacher,
there is a relation that Mark is a teacher, but if you have a sentence, Mike is not a teacher,
then there is no relation, like, it's a negation, so the model has to also figure this out, or if
you have a sentence, Jane likes to travel around the US, is there a relation between Jane and US?
Maybe there is some, but it's not important to our database, like, you're not building
facts about where Jane likes to travel to, so there is no relation in our model, and they,
so that they get like 65.1 F score, which is quite high considering you have 42 classes,
and the sentences are really long, like, the average sentence is 40 words, and the longest one
is like 96, which is quite a lot, so yeah, and then we implement a new model, we use self-attention,
plus we use this part of position of our attention, so we in the end combine them.
First, let's look at self-attention encoder, this is what we had before, it's what I try to explain
to you, and then this is our modification of that, so we change a lot of stuff, I told you we have
our own implementation of like relative embeddings, and then we don't have two residual connections,
we only have one, because we saw this works much better for the task of relation extraction,
then we also even changed like activation functions, we found out that ReLU is not
working so well here, random ReLU is much better, also layer normalization doesn't work, we tried
like different techniques, and so okay, batch normalization is working much better, then we
change a lot of stuff, maybe the most important one is that we don't have to train for like 300,000
epochs, the model actually converges in just 60, maybe it's just because less data, maybe it's just
the task, but it's just taking like one hour to get really good results, so how do we combine that,
I told you, hey this part is sort of generated by an LSTM, so let's just take that away and plug in
our output of the self-attention encoder, so we give this Q vector or Z vector,
and then we also change this other thing, they say they also want like a final output of the LSTM,
which is like the final sentence encoding, and we say okay, we can also provide that,
we just do like a max pooling layer of our self-encoder output, and hey, we are completely
replacing LSTMs in this case, so this model is attention only, it has self-attention and then on
top it's using a position of our attention created by Stanford, so yeah, what are the results,
if we compare that, we are getting better results, well not that much better, just 1.5% in general,
if you're using one model, but still better, like we are the new state of the art basically,
at least based on that data set, and what also Stanford LPE did is they also had an
assembling model, so they tried five models with different random seeds, and then did majority
wording over that, and we do the same thing, and for some reason the assembling doesn't really
work that well, we are like 0.1% there, which is, yeah, not so much, but still a bit better,
right, for this, this was all done in PyTorch, and Python obviously, so
yeah, I've been working on this for the last half a year, and I really like PyTorch coming from
Tiano or TensorFlow, I really like programming in PyTorch, so yeah, I guess it's about it,
get in touch, unfortunately our research is not published yet, we are still working on it,
but we will probably have a pre-print next week or in two weeks on Archive, and I hope in August
we'll release the source code so that everyone can use it, yeah, lots of references, take a look at
those, thank you for your attention, that's not a problem. Thanks very much Ivan for a really nice
talk, are there any questions in the audience? Yeah, over here.
Hi, thank you for the talk, I have a question about memory consumption of the model,
as we can see, like for example in the hierarchical attention models, you basically compare
every time with a context vector, and here you store matrices with similarity from all of the words
to all of the words, how extensive is memory if you don't have that much power as Google has?
Yeah, you do use up more memory, but it's much faster because it's parallelized,
so each head from this multi-head attention can be calculated in parallel, you do get like you
need more memory, but for the example we did versus relation extraction, it was okay, like
I had a GPU that's six gigabytes VRAM and it still was fine, like you don't need a, I don't know,
V100 over there. Okay, thank you. Sure.
Yeah, thanks very much for the interesting talk, one question on the latest research you did and
presented today, how did you come up with the changes you made to the architecture you're
a new model is based on? Yeah, so some of it was based on previous research from our university,
but the rest was many times trying out things, it's like deep learning is basically trying out
stuff and maybe it'll work, and I had half a year for that, so yeah, in the end, so in the paper
we're going to publish, I try to explain everything that we tried, so then you don't have to do it
again, so wait for that, there's everything explained, but this actually was a lot of trial
and error, but in the end the results are pretty good. Sure. Any more questions somewhere?
So I have one related question, so do you actually do a proper feature ablation study
when you kind of, like you did a lot of changes, so do you actually explore which part of the
change of the architecture is getting you an improvement of how many percent on that dataset?
Yeah, actually we do, again, it will be in the paper, so I have like a table comparing all the
results and we also try to visualize the models, like I showed you, you can visualize attention
and you can do the same thing with self-attention, so we go or some sentence examples and try to see
hey what's changing and what's better, so we actually like debugging it sentence by sentence
sometimes to figure out hey does this actually work? And what was the most important architecture
change? I think the residual connections, like if you only have one and then batch normalization
was huge impact and actually also using this position attention layer from Stanford helps a
lot because if you only use self-attention encoder, which you can do actually, the results are like
half of the state of the art, so you actually need this additional attention layer for that.
Okay, thank you. Any other questions? We have plenty of time for one or two over there.
I was just wondering why we use cosine and sinusoidal functions like for the positions,
like I didn't get this part too well. Yeah, I think it was just a gimmick for the paper,
like to make it look cool, but actually they actually say in the paper hey you can just use
like typical positional embeddings and the results are the same, right, but I told you there's one
difference, right, if you train a model that only sees short sentences when you do like typical
positional embeddings, it can't learn anything about the positions that are like over the ones
that you saw, but if you just run this like over cosine and sine function, it will actually give
you a wavelength, so you kind of can learn something from that. So that's like the biggest
difference I see there. Waving is like, like do you do any transformations on this functions later
on to get wavelength? Yeah, they like dividing by some constants and stuff, and the constants are
just, again, I think trial and error from the authors of the paper, they just tried so many
things and say okay this works, right, maybe they have some explanation for those, but it's hard to
like find the papers like really short. Great talk, thanks. Thanks. What do you think is
attention really all you need? Is it going to replace CNNs and LSEMs? I think so, especially
not just based on our research, but I told you OpenAI is working on this, and they have like
really really promising results, and they haven't like fully published yet, so I'm hoping they will
bring out something really cool, and then maybe we don't really need to use LSTMs or anything.
Thank you very much. More questions or yeah?
I have one more question. How can it deal with the, with text of different lengths? For example,
I have, I don't know, comments which are like 200 words, and also the others who are like only five
words length. Yeah, because the attention, the whole point of attention is that you,
you look like at word 200, but you always have this reference vector with all the attention,
so you can just look back and see, based on the probability distribution, what are the most
similar words to the one I'm looking at? So I can actually, maybe the word one is more similar,
right? And this, for example, the difference between German and English is in, in German,
you have verbs like in the end of the sentence, so the LSTM wouldn't really work that well,
so you need like buy LSTM that goes both ways, but here you don't need that because like it's
always even distribution and it always knows what to attend to. Okay, thanks. Sure. Thank you very
much. So let's thank you again for a really nice talk.